Luisa Machado centinela en el parque
nacional anti Sara su tarea de proteger
el volcán es cada vez más ardua el
deshielo avanza cada año y atenta con
dejar sin agua a la población que habita
en la capital ecuatoriana el retroceso
es de 20 a 25 metros por año y eso es
realmente preocupante es una cantidad de
retroceso muy muy pronunciada que que a
la vez afecta tanto a la producción de
agua Además del deshielo el agua que se
consume en la capital ecuatoriana
proviene de esta laguna de origen
glaciar a 35 kilómetros del volcán
antisana la crisis climática y la
escasez de lluvias amenazan estos
reservorios naturales reduciendo sus
niveles de agua
también preocupa Patricio Muñoz cuarta
parques quien conoce el lugar desde hace
40 años para proteger la diversidad
vegetal siembra huertos que aspira
convertir en 5000 nuevas plantas al año
la vegetación puede constantemente por
la falta lluvias y el incremento del sol
se contabilizaban hasta 300 días de
lluvia no y apenas teníamos un mes
entre medio seco o medio húmedo hoy
totalmente ha cambiado
me agrada que la zona de amortiguamiento
aún la tenemos además de la flora
también la fauna está sufriendo de los
estragos de los cambios de temperatura
ante la migración de muchas especies
Luisa vigila que el cóndor ave típica
nacional en peligro de extinción
permanezca en su hábitat natural
camino al antisana el desgaste glaciar
revela sus capas rocosas a kilómetros de
distancia y confirma nuevas amenazas las
microplásticos Y eso también es un
factor que durante años ya sea por
actividades turísticas por actividades
antrópicas y el mismo ambiente ya tiene
micro plásticos y están depositados en
el Nevado En total son 120.000 hectáreas
diarias protegidas amenazadas de
desaparecer este parque natural
poblaciones enteras quedarían sin agua y
ya no existiría el ecosistema más rico
de Ecuador